serge dassault et l'ancien secrétaire
général de l'otan le belge willy claes
ont donc été condamné aujourd'hui à des
peines de prison avec sursis dans la
sphère agusta d'assaut l'avionneur
français a été reconnu coupable de
corruption active dans le cadre d'un
marché d'armement est condamné à deux
ans de prison avec sursis à bruxelles
pascal verneau
la dernière épreuve pour serge dassault
ce matin jusqu'au bout l'avionneur
français se sera battus pour préserver
son honneur et celui de son groupe il y
a cinq semaines devant les magistrats de
la cour de cassation il n'y est encore
toute responsabilité personnelle dans le
da sont mon nom celui de ma famille a
été
entachée d'accusations
basée sur des mensonges qui sont les
menteurs pour la cour de cassation serge
dassault ne peut être cru lorsqu'il se
prétend étrangers au pacte corrupteurs
et les juges enfonce le clou il existe
bien un lien une relation de cause à
effet entre les dons reçus par les
partis socialistes belges et
l'attribution du marché à l'entreprise
os d électronique serge dassault c'est
d'ailleurs cet homme ancien ministre de
la défense guillaume qui a favorisé
contre l'avis de ses militaires l'offre
de dassault face à un concurrent
américain comme et dassault réunis
aujourd'hui dans la même peine deux ans
de prison avec sursis avec humilité
serge dassault avait demandé
personnellement il ya un mois la
suspension du prononcé du jugement pas
question ont répondu les juges belges
aujourd'hui serge dassault est un des
instigateurs de la corruption ce qu'il a
fait est inacceptable